All right. So, here's what I did.
I gave you the choice of two different methods,
either writing your own code to calculate the accuracy, or using sklearn.
What I myself chose to do was to use the sklearn accuracy_score,
which is what you'll find if you Google sklearn accuracy.
And so, this is just a function that takes a bunch of predictions,
it takes a bunch of labels, and then goes through and
does the element by element comparison.
And then will give you the accuracy that,
that your classifier has on your test set.
So, hopefully, what you got, and what I got for the accuracy is about 88.4%.
So, 88.4% of the points are being correctly labelled by our
classifier when we use our test set.